>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> ...her neighborhood,
Ms. Alexander lives
on just the other side
of the capital.
She'll be talking today
not only about her new book
which is called Parallel Worlds:
The Remarkable Gibbs-Hunts
and the Enduring Insignificance
of Melanin; but also something
about now, about the district that
she's called home for a long time,
about the extended family that she's
a part of that's had such influence
in the district, in the
culture, in the nation;
and also of note her daughter
who [inaudible] inevitably early
this morning was seen just in front
of that white building over there
as Barack Obama's inaugural poet
also interviewed Lonae [assumed
spelling] Anelle Parker's
[inaudible] this morning.
So without hesitation, I want to
welcome Adele Logan Alexander.
[ Applause ]
>> Adele Alexander: I thank
you all so much for coming.
I've been writing history for
a long time; studying history,
teaching history, writing
history for a long time.
And we sometimes as academic
historians feel as if we sort
of labor in caves; and very few
people outside the academic world
knows what we're about, knows
what we are writing about
and then you talk to groups of 12
people-- 12 enthusiastic people.
But then when we come
across something
like this incredible National
Book Festival and the support
from the Library of Congress,
created by the Library of Congress,
supported by the Washington
Post and my introducer and then
of course I was so thrilled, my
daughter and I were so thrilled
when Lonae's piece came
out in the Washington Post
and everybody's been coming up to
me here I am obscure historian.
Everybody comes up to me and
says I just saw your picture;
I just read about you and
your daughter and so on.
And also it is so absolutely unique
and wonderful that my daughter
and I have the privilege
of appearing here together
at the National Book Festival; and
of course she had a poem that kind
of made her famous that was heard
by two billion with a b people
around the world so I come here
standing before you most humbly
in appreciation.
I'm going to talk not for
very long and I'll talk--
they didn't tell me until just
now that I was also going to talk
about my family and our role
in the District of Columbia.
But I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about my book
and maybe we can get to the other
stuff in questions because I'd love
to have some give and take with
you and what you are interested in
or you might be interested
in with this particular book;
and about African-American
history and women's history
and whatever else you're
thinking about.
So let me just talk to you about
ten minutes about this book.
I have to put this
down because the space
under here won't accommodate it.
Okay so here we go.
One of the things that is
particularly enjoyable about talking
about this particular book
which is called Parallel Worlds:
The Remarkable Gibbs-Hunts and the
Enduring Insignificance of Melanin,
is that different readers,
different audiences suggest
different approaches.
Different audiences come to
it with different interests
and there's plenty of me here
in the book to approach it
from a variety of different
directions.
At George Washington University
where I have been teaching
since 1994, they asked me
last winter to fit this
in with their black history
month's theme about the new Negro
in Washington, D.C. in the
1920's; and of course I did that;
I talked about black women's issues
and black women's political activism
at the Women's National
Democratic Club.
So I did that there,
then just recently
at the D.C. Historical Society
I joined a panel where we talked
about how things have changed and
things have not changed in terms
of African American's and women's
influence in foreign relations;
and foreign relations is a very
important part of this book.
But the Library of Congress
when I spoke there last winter
advertised this as being
about a remarkable mixed race family
so this gives me an opportunity
to talk about those
aspects of Parallel Worlds.
Given the great variety and
accelerated discussions and debates
that we've had in the last few years
about so-called mixed race people
in the United States, most
obviously certainly our President,
plus the fact that relatively
recently as of the 2000 census
and of course we've just
taken another census,
but as the 2000 census, we
could talk about mixed races
and claim ourselves as having all
kinds of different racial heritage.
So I don't know whether any of you
in fact saw the Henry
Louis Gates series
on television called
Faces of America.
And one of the things
that he is emphasizing
in that is how many
interrelationships we have racially,
culturally and so on.
Just as a very amusing
aside, Stephen Colbert
who interviewed my daughter
after she was the Inaugural Poet,
and he is a neighbor of my
son in Mt. Clair, New Jersey,
and they have been working
on ellipticals together
and so they've known
each other for some time.
And it turns out from
Skip Gates' research
that in fact we are cousins;
and of course in his own driveway
Stephen Colbert says, "No, no,
no I am the whitest man in America."
But it did introduce us to
all kinds of different things.
So I'm going to inform you a little
bit I hope and challenge you to some
of these questions as I talk.
And one of the things that I do know
and that most of us in this room
who identify ourselves as
African Americans know too,
at least this is true for those of
us who are, shall we say, over 50,
that regardless of our physical
features, skin color, hair texture,
all of those things, we
always thought of ourselves
in my childhood the word
of course was negroes.
More recently we became blacks,
then we became African-Americans.
We didn't think of-- we old
generation didn't think of ourselves
as being of mixed race; there
was no question about that.
And this was a matter that
was shaped by a lot of things.
It was shaped by custom,
it was shaped by law,
and it was also very much shaped
by pride in racial accomplishments.
That's not to say of course that
we didn't know pretty much for sure
that in our families several
generations back there was indeed a
complex racial history some place
several generations back or more.
There often were add mixtures
of white blood and I use
that word blood which we all know is
a metaphor; it doesn't really mean
and I always see quotation
marks whenever I say blood
in that context.
And we also, many of us, had Native
American so-called blood as well.
We also knew and know that in most
cases this whiteness had intruded
on our Africanness through
white male per genitors,
and it was not always something
that came consensually.
I recently heard a lecture
at the National Endowment
for the Humanities in which a
grantee has developed a massive
database of the Atlanta
Slave Trade almost 400 years.
And one of the statistics
gleaned from that
and this is totally amazing to me --
I've done history for
more than 20 years,
that until the mid 1800's the
ratio of black women being brought
to this country, in other words
African women, to white women--
the women who came here voluntarily,
that that ratio was
9 to 1-- amazing.
So obviously what we know from this
is that most of the European men
who cross the Atlantic did not
come with their wives so some
but few Native American women were
available to them so in many cases
of course their sexual
partners were African slaves.
The other interesting and
unique thing that happened
in the new United States
in the 1800's was there
was a virtual reversal
of the old tradition that was so
prevalent in English common law
which determined that
the condition--
the legal condition of a
child followed the condition
of the mother.
Now that meant that when we
turned that concept upside down,
the child of a slave woman was also
therefore enslaved in perpetuity.
That determination
did a lot of things.
It both saved white men
from having any moral
or financial responsibility
for their offspring,
and it also ensured an ever-growing,
ever-sufficient enslaved population
for a new country that
grounded its economy and much
of its wealth enslaved labor.
Especially that was true after 1807
when the International
Slave Trade was banned;
in other words you couldn't
bring anymore enslaved Africans
into the country.
So that dramatically
curtailed the availability,
the supposedly limitless
supply of those people.
Another factor soon crept
into this complex equation
and that was again something
that's unique in the United States,
sort of a binary definition
of race itself.
In other words in the United States
anybody who is not certifiably
"white" all white so to speak,
anyone with any so-called trace
of Negro blood was
designated both in law
and in practice to be a Negro.
So this is very different
from the situation even
in the Western hemisphere
where various degrees
of so-called Negro-ness gave people
varying amounts of privilege,
varying amounts of
protections under the law;
sometimes that included getting
your freedom; So I tell you this
to introduce some of the
specific circumstances
in which the two intertwine
families-- the Gibbs and the Hunts,
whom I write about in Parallel
Worlds found themselves
in the 19th Century which is
when my story takes place.
So let me tell you a little
bit more about the book
and how these people
that I write about.
My main protagonists are Ida
Gibbs-Hunt and William Henry Hunt;
how they came to be part of
these mixed race families.
Both of these are fascinating
people to whom I was drawn
in the first place because I love
biography; I love family history;
I have written two family
history books before this one;
my first one was Ambiguous Lives and
my second one was the American Saga
of Homelands and Waterways: The
American Saga of the Bond Family.
I saw in their marriage, this
marriage of Ida and William,
a remarkable balance of power,
balance of gender power.
That was singular in their era but
certainly it's hard to document
and certainly that
was an era when women
for the most part played very
subservient roles to men.
I also wanted of course to tell a
good story because what I love to do
with history is the story part
of it and telling good stories
because that's what attracts me.
and I think that's what
attracts a lot of you as well.
William Henry Hunt actually
became the first African American
to have a full career
with the State Department.
And thus he lived around
the world for 35 years,
most of it with his wife.
Ida also was a significant
intellectual.
She was a major organizer of W.E.
B. Dubois' Pan African Congresses
in Europe in the 1920's
so there was plenty
of heft to both of their lives.
These people also provided me with a
lot of documentary evidence to help
in recreating their stories.
Ida's father, Mifflin Gibbs,
wrote and published an
autobiography in 1902.
She herself published
extensively and she left scads
of personal letters as did her
sister and her brother-in-law.
Now William Hunt wrote but he
didn't manage to get it published,
a memoir of his own, as
well as a number of articles
and he too left a plethora
of personal professional
correspondence.
William and-- I'll
call him Billy now
because he becomes Billy
early in my narrative.
He was born into slavery
in 1863 in rural Tennessee.
He apparently never felt the need
to say specifically a white man was
my father, but he knew from family
and friends that his father did live
in the nearby so-called big house,
that being of course the
phrase that was always used
for the master's house
in the antebellum south.
And as I write about Billy's
account of his paternity he says,
"Stories like these offer
anecdotal the credible confirmation
that my wielding their
physical, sexual, economic
and emotional powers, such white
men have significantly lightened
so-called black America's
collective complexion while
with apparent indifference,
they contributed
to widespread illegitimacy
in that community."
So one of the things that we
talk about all the time now
and appropriately so is
illegitimacy in the Black community;
but one of my arguments
in this is to say
that this was first an
imposed illegitimacy that came
out of the traditions of slavery.
His mother, Billy's mother,
I determined belonged
to a slave-owning widower
whose name was William H. Hunt.
She gave her oldest son his name
with whom she had six children.
I judge from that account
combined with census documentation
of both Billy and his mother;
and from Billy's appearance he was
quite light-skinned, light-haired--
- light eyes, curly hair that to use
our metaphor again he probably had
considerably more so-called white
blood and so-called black blood.
Nonetheless as I also explained
before for purposes of law
and in practice, he was
in fact designated a Negro
and he never tried to
seriously circumvent
that identification
although he could have.
Another question arises because I
think he perhaps may have had Native
American ancestors when he was a
council in France in the 1920's.
There was an article
written in a French newspaper
that said he was a po
rouge [assumed spelling]--
that common but ugly
designation of a redskin.
Perhaps Billy Hunt heard that rumor
and repeated it in his host country
but anyway it became
common news in France.
So the French it seemed in
the 1920's really wanted
to differentiate him
and his wife Ida
from the truly black colonial
Africans whom they knew something
about and whom they
considered very primitive.
They didn't consider-- they thought
that Billy Hunt was
a sophisticated man.
He was an American; he
was educated and so forth.
Ida Alexander Gibbs came from
another such mixed race family
and her story as I document it
is perhaps ever more intriguing
although we do hear these
stories from time to time.
Family lore combined
with other anecdotal
and census records reveals a
lineage that's very interesting
on her maternal side.
I argue that Ida's maternal
grandfather was a man named Richard
Mentor Johnson.
You probably don't know that name;
I didn't know it before I undertook
this endeavor and I should know
such things because I'm
supposed to be an historian.
But he was very well known
in his time because from 1837
to 1841 he was Vice President
of the United States--
Martin Van Buren's Vice President.
Before that period, during
that period Johnson was a Kentucky
slave owner, he had been a Senator.
He officially remained a
bachelor throughout his life.
There's a lot of documentation,
a lot of speculation
about his relationships especially
with a woman named Julia Chinn
with whom he had two daughters
whom he acknowledged and supported.
But according to many accounts Julia
Chinn was not the only slave woman
with whom he had sexual relations,
and sometimes he kept more
than one mistress of
color at the same time.
Several biographies suggest
that he also had liaisons with
and prepare yourselves for this--
this one sort of shocked
me-- with Julia's two nieces.
One was named Patience Chinn
and the other was named Lucy Chinn
Alexander, Lucy being the mother
of my protagonist Ida Gibbs.
One such story which I quote in
my books suggests that Lucy had
"about the complexion of
Shakespeare's worthy Othello.
Who knows what this worthy
Othello's complexion was like?
But in any case she at least
had one child by that white man,
Maria, who was Ida's mother.
Most evidence suggests that
it was Richard Mentor Johnson,
Vice President, who was her father.
I think that these stories are true
and they also lead me to suspect
that the Chinn family had Native
American forbears as well.
Several accounts suggest that Maria
ran away from our R.M. Johnson
with assistance of a Chaukta
[assumed spelling] Indian man.
So descriptions of the
women in the family also say
that they were copper-skinned
and they had straight
black hair and so on.
So I think that they probably had
Native American blood as well.
My book accounts the early life
of Ida's father, Mifflin Gibbs,
but his experiences while equally
remarkable do not include any
such accounts of white men who
used or misused their slave women
and father their children.
So those are some of the
stories about Ida Gibbs
and William Hunt's ancestries
that I account in Parallel World;
which leads to the designation
of them in today's Lexicon
as being so-called
mixed race family.
Now let's fast forward a little
to the early 20th Century.
Billy Hunt first followed his
very successful father-in-law
to the Consulate in colonial
Madagascar in 1898 and then
after ten years in Madagascar he
went on to 20 years in France,
then he was sent to Guadalupe
and in 1929 he found himself
in the mid-Atlantic
Portuguese Azores,
a local that he found
to be quite idyllic.
At that time and here we get
into some of the personal stories
that are intertwined,
he had correspondence
with a young Negro woman named
Caroline Bond-Day whose mother was a
close friend of Billy's wife, Ida.
Caroline wanted a photograph
of Council Hunt to add
to the collection that
she was pulling together
at Harvard University
for her pending Master's
Degree in Anthropology.
When her work was complete,
she became the first self-identified
Negro anywhere in the country
to earn a graduate
degree in that field.
In 1932 Harvard published
her thesis under the title,
a Study of Some Negro White
Families in the United States.
The work seems a bit primitive by
today's standards of anthropology,
but it was far in a way the
earliest study of its kind
and I know a great deal about it
because Caroline Bond-Day
was my mother's older sister,
she was my aunt and my
mother worked on this thesis
in the book during
her college summers.
It was a treasured fixture in my
house as I was growing up and that's
where I first saw the
photograph of William Henry Hunt.
One reason it intrigued me
was because he looked so much
like members of my
father's maternal family
and they too had the surname Hunt.
My mother assured me that that Hunts
were not related to Council Hunt.
I'd like to be able to tell you
that I definitely learned otherwise
in this book but I didn't;
I don't think we're related.
What I learned is that
Ida Gibbs Hunt
and William Henry Hunt definitely
did meet one of my relatives,
a great uncle in Paris in 1921.
This sort of expands our
ideas of all the things
that African-Americans
did at that point.
They had mutual friends
in Washington
and probably met again n the
1930's when Billy Hunt had retired
from the State Department.
Henry Hunt, a well known educator
arrived here in 1934 to serve
as what was then called Franklin
Delano Roosevelt's black cabinet.
I don't know whether
you know that term.
Of course they were really cabinet
members; the first cabinet member--
real cabinet member was Robert
Weaver who was appointed
by Linda Johnson in 1965.
But it was the first time
that any sizeable number
of African Americans held
positions of substance
in the Federal Government.
I'd like to close my formal
presentation with a little
of what Dubois wrote
posthumously [assumed spelling]
about Henry Alexander
Hunt which I include
in the epilogue of Parallel Worlds.
He asked rhetorically
why Hunt, my great uncle,
had stayed so resonantly within
the African American community,
never taking the easier path and
opted to become the white man
that his physiog [assumed
spelling] declared him.
When, as Dubois wrote, thousands of
men and women like him have done so.
Those thousands who chose to pass
for white included several members
of the Hunt family I write about
there, and my Hunt family as well.
The overwhelming and I'm
continuing with Dubois opinion
of white Americans, is that
one black ancestors in 8
or 16 makes a tremendous
difference of identity
of treatment of opportunity.
And then he went on to take a stand
in America, however; as anything
but a Negro would have
made him extremely unhappy
because here was an opportunity
for battle on the highest plane.
Life is primarily friends and family
and one cannot lightly cast off
this enveloping and intriguing bond
of love and affection to create
a new place in a strange world.
So I've barely touched on 30 years
of living, working and adventuring
around the world that's
at the core of this book
about the remarkable Gibbs-Hunts.
But I hope that this discussion
of mixed race families has given
you a taste of what's in my book;
something to think about,
something to chew over and I hope
that you will be stimulated
to ask questions.
We don't have terribly much time
but I would love it and I thank you
so much for your attentiveness.
This is wonderful.
[ Applause ]
Adele Alexander: Yes Sir?
>> Audience question: In
your significant study
of African-American families and I
guess particularly mixed families,
how often did you come across
the use of skin products--
skin lighteners or whiteners or even
darkeners; or was that something
that you were able to research or
was that something that was talked
about at all or written about?
>> Adele Alexander: Certainly
I don't write about it
because I never found
it in any of the people
that I happen to write about.
However, I've done a lot of
work with a woman you may know
about whose name is A'lelia Bundles
whose great grandmother was Madame
C.J. Walker who developed
hair straightening--
she called them hair health
products, skin health products
that also served to create a
more-- a whiter appearance.
But I guess that one of the things
is that it almost seems remarkable
to me not that so many
people did these things,
but that so many did not.
Because in our culture there
was so much of a premium
that has been placed on whiteness--
day to day inconveniences,
legal restrictions
and everything else.
It's easy for me to understand why
a number of black people wanted
to be part of the majority in
this country because they were
so discriminated against
and any steps
in that direction I think
were understandable.
>> Audience question: I've enjoyed
your presentation very much.
My friend and I came
here from Georgia;
we're both from the Deep
South, rural Georgia,
and wonder about your connection
to Georgia given your earlier book,
Ambiguous Lives, and just wondered
if you'd comment about that.
>> Adele Alexander:
I'm a big city girl.
I'm a total Northerner, I
grew up in New York City
and I didn't know anything
whatsoever
about Georgia beside Atlanta,
the world of the Deep South,
sort of began and ended for me
with the Atlanta suburbs
when I was growing up.
And then in the 1980's,
the early 1980's I was--
also I should add sort of on
my own bio, that I went back
to graduate school when my children
were going to graduate school
so I was a very old
graduate student--
And so in case you all got confused
about my age and my white hair.
But so this was in the 1980's
that I went down to rural Georgia
and the ruralness of it
was a revolution to me.
The degree to which the South was
still-- much of the rural south,
not Atlanta, that's one
of the big differences.
The rural south was still
held captive by its traditions
of segregation but
also how community
and family retain traditions that
we-- when we move to urban areas,
we move to the North, we
sometimes lose these things.
And I just totally became engrossed
in this family of mine that came
out of Hancock County, Georgia
which at one time was the most
populous county in the State;
and it is now just such
a total sad backorder.
But there I found the most wonderful
family and friend so that's a lot
of my connection with Georgia.
Oh thank you so much.
They're holding up a big sign
in here that says overtime.
I think they're going to cut off
my mic any time, any moment now
so let me once again
thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Adele Alexander: And if I
can just add one quick thing.
For some reason they scheduled
my book signing before and not
after my talk which is crazy,
but if any of you do want
books signed I would be more
than delighted to do so.
Thank you again.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.